don't you dare hang up that phone okay
why shouldn't i why should
what if i wanted the vegas package
you know what i want the vegas package
sure you do
what
you mother
please don't come
this is all about susie diaz it's susie
diaz's party susie diaz is running the
show i'm just gonna show up if she needs
me to bring beer or something i'm more
than happy to do
oh dude oh my god a woman just fainted
i'm gonna have to call you back
ma'am
man
9-1-1 what is your emergency yes yeah
i'm on the corner of a fifth and
metropolitan and i just came up across
this woman and she just she just passed
out
on the sidewalk here okay and is she
responsive sir
um
okay sir is she responsive
sir
sir
um no sir if you can hear me she's not
responsible she's beautiful
[Music]
that is not relevant to this emergency
sir an ambulance is on its way in the
meantime i need you to check her pulses
up to check her pulse right check it
pulse okay
does she have a pulse sir
no she does but her skin is so soft
she doesn't have a ton of makeup but
she's the kind of girl that just doesn't
need it
you can see that she put a lot of
thought into her outfit but that was
just trying too hard
she's perfect
so may i remind you that you have not
spoken a word to this woman i need you
to see if she's breathing uh yeah
[Music]
sir i need you to stay on track
okay she's not breathing but look my
life is not breathing you gotta save my
baby do you know how to give
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation yes i do
okay i need you to administer that now
okay okay
no no i can't i can't
i can't do it i can't i can't do it it's
just it's disrespectful i have to be
respectful for her sir this is the only
time it's okay to put your mouth on an
unconscious woman do it i just didn't
picture it happening this way there's
butterflies in my stomach and i'm just i
i don't want to mess this up it's so
rare to buy sorry if you can hear me
[Music]
all right
[Music]
9-1-1 what is your emergency there's an
attractive confident
do black manny he just passed out right
here on the street
okay ma'am listen very carefully i'm
going to need you to marry him
oh okay
shouldn't i give him like mouth-to-mouth
first
yeah girl get you some shoe
[Music]
hello skymall magazine this is riaz
speaking hello riaz i would like to
report an item which i ordered that
arrived broken
wendell sanders mockingbird lane that's
right i am showing the last item that
you've received is the superman bed with
the mattress of solitude that's the one
ordered it from a son for his birthday
but i cannot give it to him like this
and i'm pretty darn tootin pissed about
it
sorry sir i will start processing your
reorder right now with you on the line
okay i ain't mad at you rios it's just
the system i know okay thank you for
understanding sir
kids eh
huh
oh
okay well yeah i just got the one myself
had sex with a woman and everything to
get him
how long is this going what is your
son's name
oh
uh
stimpy
pretty much stimpy i have boys too i'll
tell you sometimes they can be a real
couple of universes
you're preaching to the choir
stimpy don't you give me that look
you're gonna get it when your mama comes
home oh man sounds like your wife is
[ __ ] on wheels you got that straight
riaz
hot little biscuit though name's claire
body10 face 10. so
pretty much hit that every night
sexually
anyway what's holding up one more minute
and uh how old is your son
15. 15.
and he still wants a superman bed
a late bloomer
enjoy it while you still can
he'll grow out of the toys any day now
they all do
and the second he starts hooking up with
the girls he'll forget all about that
superman and spiderman stuff
pretty much seems like how it would
happen
maybe then he'll stop bothering me with
all those stupid little facts about how
those characters you just named are
clearly from two distinct and separate
universes sadly some people never move
on sad i got a better word for you
pathetic well i i i wouldn't say but
that's okay hey i caused them locks i
see some reals and i don't tolerate
nerds in fact let me nip this in the bud
real quick stimp it stimpy get back in
here i will i didn't mean to there you
are with your brown body and your creepy
ass face no more sweets for you cause
you're never gonna get laid if you keep
eating sweets and another thing
all these
figurines and toys you got around the
house we're throwing them in the trash
cause they're not real people stimpy
they're not real people so stop being so
lonely stop being
so lonely
[Music]
well
and this is none of my business of
course
but i was wondering if your
son
would like to talk to someone
oh simply just jumped out the window oh
my gosh oh he killed himself why to do
it it must have been my fault no it
wasn't yes it was i'm gonna call the
cops don't you dare cancel that reorder
it's the only thing i'll have to
remember him bye
hello this is gavin
hi gavin my name is colin valente i'm
calling for master travel incorporated
tell you about an exciting living time
an exclusive las vegas getaway i have a
female 1 to your time to tell you about
this new package you know what i would
love to but i just don't have the time
hello
hello
foreign
[Music]
this is colin valencia master travel
incorporated i may be a service uh hi
colin valenti my name is uh gavin i
think we just talked uh did we get
disconnected
yeah no i mean yeah i hung up on you
uh why would you do that
i mean are you even
are you even allowed to do that
well were you going to buy the las vegas
package
well i mean probably not but that's not
the point the point is
what the hell
this is colin yeah valenti listen um i
don't know what crawled up your ass and
set up shop there but you don't get to
hang up
[Music]
what
oh my god
[Music]
what the [ __ ] do you want what is your
deal huh
um you don't want the biggest package so
i don't want to talk because it's a
favor wasting our time stop stop don't
you dare hang up that phone okay
why shouldn't i why should
what if i wanted the vegas package
you know what i want the vegas package
sure you do
what
little mother
oh my god you son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
come on man let it go
new man you i want five
packages right now you know what you
know what my wallet this is my credit
card number right here okay this
my credit card number is your0745
zero zero nine eight the expiration date
is twelve twenty and then and then uh
yeah the security number is zero eight
four so run the damn card right now
right now you run it right now [ __ ]
thank you for your business
well i hope you learned
these new call scripts are really great
yeah i know right
what the [ __ ] do you want kathy
call my agent
jaden pickett smith my man what up clyde
hey look man i'm gonna be real with you
okay this alien boy script i'm not
feeling it i mean it's hard being will
smith's son i just want to make sure my
next project reflects that i'm a
down-to-earth normal kid am i making any
sense yeah yeah i'm reading you loud
clear i've got a script right here very
real called street ball talk to me okay
so you play tony he's a kid from the
streets lives in the hood in a house
with his mom stop
house
oh it's like a
tiny mansion got it go on so his mom and
he uh they live in this house and she
works at a supermarket ah
oh uh a supermarket's like a mansion uh
but it's full of food and anyone can go
there so like where the butlers go
yeah basically so so he uh and wait you
said his mom was doing something at the
supermarket working so
working is kind of like acting on a set
every day in a film that no one's ever
gonna see and it lasts for the rest of
your life oh like a maid
yeah
yeah of the supermarket awesome continue
so anyway tony doesn't make the
basketball team right so he decides to
start playing pickup games of street
ball outside so
he plays basketball in his plane
no on the ground
in his limo
no uh outside is that stuff that goes by
when you're inside the limo oh snap he
plays basketball outside the limo door
yeah yeah yeah yeah so then he gets
really good at basketball and then blah
blah blah blah fast forward at the heart
of the story tony has to choose between
his mom
yeah choose is when you have to make a
decision between two things you want but
you can have only one
but
there's two
yeah but i mean
he can't have both
what'd i say about science fiction clyde
it's a no
okay we'll pass
dad bless you thanks
hello thanks for calling mario's pizza
this is carlo speaking oh wow
we would like a large pie with a
pepperoni pineapple and cheesy crust
large pepperoni with pineapple and
cheesy crust
we
would also like a large pie with bacon
pineapple
and cheesy crust large bacon pineapple
with cheesy crust okay is that gonna
complete your order sir you know what
let me gauge the room uh guys we gonna
want another pizza let me just who's
hungry show her hands let me see them
one two three keep them up four five six
ah having a party
yup pretty big one two come on guys keep
them up hugo summer hands food you know
what let's play it safe let's get
another pie pineapple all right um
oh you guys are gonna need cheesy crust
on the third good question i'll gauge
the room hey guys do we want cheesy
crust on the third okay yeesh that is a
resounding yes for cheesy crust on the
third
claire says you read her mind claire huh
i like that name it's a good one oh also
uh my boy andy over here is saying you
have something called chicken poppers is
she cute uh who's that now claire oh
her body's like a four anyway we would
also
how do you mean
let's just say she's kind of a big girl
that's all good
that's all superficial man i like claire
for what's inside don't even know claire
yo but for real though i feel like i do
know claire man
put me on the phone with her
uh
you don't need to speak to claire no i
do
you know what
i gotta level with you man
i
i didn't mean to
get in between you guys no
it's quite all right
twas a while ago before she blinked up
my current girlfriends live
body
tan face
tan
but anyway claire yeah
i hit that
sexually and uh as did my boy hugo hell
even bubba got some of that
so just wanted you to know used goods to
use goods
so you wouldn't care if i asked her out
well
let me do it for you hey claire this guy
from the pizza place wants to date you
too poor all right i'll let him down
wait wait wait wait wait no
tell her
no i'm not a rich man
but i'm a good man tell her claire i
believe in destiny
and i believe that we've always known
that our soul mate was out there the
moment that we
had that unspoken connection about the
cheesy crust
i realized that you were always the one
because
and i know this sounds corny
but that moment
was just like
simple
wow
you really do care about claire
[Music]
i do
oh my god claire just got shot what no
oh it just came through the window it
was a bullet in the neck oh claire's
down she's dead she's dead i'm calling
the cop she's dead
chinese it is
because you're my wife and you love the
theater and uh it's your birthday
great
un unfortunately the um
the orchestra is already filled up but
they do have seats that are still left
in the dress circle so if you want to um
me to get them theater tickets right now
i'm gonna do it right now what's up dawg
i'm about five minutes away yeah okay
yeah cool no they're all good singers
they're all good singing yeah son
nah man i'm about i'm telling you man
i'm about to cross the street oh they
got that one dude in it that you love
man he gonna be in it yeah come on now
you know i'm almost there all right
right now i'm gonna pick your ass up at
6 30 then cool all right yeah yeah yeah
yeah the parking is uh the park is free
it's already got that oh my god
christian i almost totally just got
mugged right now
oh
[Music]